well I want to talk to you about your
career a little bit too because you know
you're you're it's one of those things
where you're very good at a lot of
different things I know you had a career
as a or maybe still have a career as a
Cartoonist I've done a little I've
dabbled in cartoon I've never enough to
make a living out of it but but enough
to get suspended in high school correct
somebody's been doing their homework uh
so yeah you want me to tell that story
Al Jaffe was this great cartoonist with
Mad Magazine subversive and there would
be like a picture in writing and then
you would fold it in instead of folding
it out and it would create some other
image and some other it'll be some
commentary on something so my friends
and I we were out for Chinese food one
time in high school I think we might
have been cutting school and we were
talking about Mad Magazine foldings and
some of the members of the yearbook
staff were there this is when we were
seniors and we talked about maybe we
should do a fold and so I devised a fold
in because I was the cartoonist and
um
the chief delinquent among this gang and
you know when we got it into the
yearbook it was a full page ad and it
was it was the 40th year of the school
the 40th anniversary of the school so I
drew a big 40th year with balloons in
this and I and we made up a family I
went to a Jewish school like a like
religious school uh Akiba Hebrew Academy
is what it was called it's called
something else now well when you when
you opened it it said you know the
Morgan Stearns of Woodward Pennsylvania
congratulate the school blah blah blah
40th year blah blah blah blah when you
folded it in
it said for all the BS eat this and
there was in the 40th year became a
giant penis
and the balloons became testicles and it
was
um and we made it to graduation day
without anyone figuring it out
but then they figured it out before
graduation and so yeah we got in trouble
we had to do community service we had to
apologize I understand I read you had to
do community service it's not a crime
like what would you have to go pick up
trash on the highway it was you know
what I remember just like hammering I
just remember ripping Nails out of
boards while everybody else was taking
the SATs or something taking their final
exams it was just they didn't know what
to do uh they had to punish us we
literally graduate like I got an I got
an empty naugahyde folder when I marched
in graduation there was no diploma in
there I had to come back we had to write
this apology letter it actually and then
we wrote one of the teachers who we
loved um I don't want to get him in
trouble but his name was Steve uh and
Steve came in when we were writing the
apology letter because he knew that for
all the BS ethos was not aimed at him I
don't even know who it was aimed at I
don't know what we were rebelling
against but uh he said don't apologize
for anything you don't want to apologize
for so we did the Washington DC you know
we're sorry we regret if anybody was a
offended kind of thing and that was the
end of that and then
um yeah that was my dad was not happy he
was very how'd you guys get caught
somebody told somebody and you know
and like you know it I don't want to say
it leaked out because that's a horrible
pun but but uh yeah yeah people found
out about it and then next thing you
knew the teachers had heard about it and
people were demanding the teachers were
demanding punishment it didn't say to
the teachers right every yearbook after
that had to go through a very vigorous
uh vetting process for every single page
foreign